comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
inutile de dire à quel point nous sommes
flattés de vous accueillir sur ce
plateau tom wolfe coup c'est un grand
plaisir d'être ici je connais très peu
de français j'ai appris quelques mots au
sujet de la féminisation du monde alors
je connais quelques mots en français
pour le dire c'est très vrai dans cette
histoire de famille né sur ce que vous
savez par exemple que on peut
reconnaître les gens à leur chapeau
regardez les chapeaux de quelqu'un il ya
cent ans les hommes portaient ces
chapeaux qui qui était en fait rigide
comme les femmes n'ont commencé à
prendre le pouvoir il fallait que ces
chapeaux ça me lis un petit peu c'est
donc les hommes ont commencé à porter
ses chats peu plus mou et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ils portent des casquettes
de baseball à l'envers et c'est ça la
féminisation du monde en feu par la joie
vestimentaire vous êtes d'accord avec
eric zemmour le monde se féminise tout à
fait raison que tu bénéficies une suti
alors la saint jean la star des lettres
américaines
il a pas dix c'était bien il faut avoir
une vision xtra environnementale pour
pouvoir prouver que vous avez raison là
dessus là ça y est la rive est content
je le mets qui vient spécialement des
états unis pour se donner raison
tom moi c'est le costume noir où c'est
le costume blanc vous avez dit davantage
de portes et toujours le même costume
c'est que ça donne une idée aux
journalistes pour commencer leurs
papiers et une fois vous aviez fini très
mauvaise interview mais le journaliste
avait été fasciné par votre costume et
vous avez compris que ce n'était pas la
peine d'avoir une personnalité
il suffisait d'avoir un costume blanc
effectivement et c'est tout ce que j'ai
ce soir
cela étant il ya une chose comme airs et
qui est très nouveau
enfin quelque chose qui viennent des
états unis justement et que je vais vous
présenter ce soir
regardez c'est ce qu'on appelle une
cravate cépages en pao cannes ou au kilo
traceur regarder audibien vous cravate
on français pour cet objet est alors je
peux vous dire où vous pouvez retrouver
si ça vous intéresse vous êtes le
dernier à porter une cravate je croyais
être le premier jeu ça fait tellement
longtemps que j'ai vu des cravates j'ai
pas vu en france en tout cas depuis mon
arrivée alors tom moult vous êtes à 75
ans le dandy terrible de la littérature
américaine
on vous doit le gauchisme de park avenue
le mot pain les toffes des héros acid
test le bûcher des vanités et un homme
un vrai
pas mal
énorme écrivains en france je suis très
impressionné quand je savais qu'il était
là j'avais presque le trac espèce
d'inquiétude
j'ai acheté plein de livres pour les
faire dédicacer pour le garder dans la
bibliothèque mois écouter pour moi c'est
un mythe ça vous ne savez plus grands
écrivains vivants et je dois dire je
fais partie de ces journalistes qui ont
été élevés au lait de tom hall
quand il avait je suis un de ceux livre
qui a été un choc pour moi royaume dans
ses articles dans rolling stones kiss
reste absolument mythique et il avait
écrit ce livre vous souvenez kita
recueil d'articles gauchisme le
gauchiste de par cadre amical chez sorti
chez gallimard en 1972 vous soyez encore
moi ça a changé ma vie je suis je sus
prix comme plein de journalistes
françaises et fait des petits partout en
france pourtant volte face à elle
voilà et et c est après évidemment je ne
parle pas du bûcher des vanités de tous
ses livres merveilleux enfin j'ai pas
encore lu le dernier mais à chaque fois
ma pour moi ton vol c'est joli je me
précipite sur le vous nous décrire passé
ce reproche que je peux vous faire quand
même
c'est vrai c'est que vous êtes un peu
circonspect quand même alors peut-être
que vous écrivez beaucoup plus que vous
publiez
mais ça manque à il faut attendre
parfois cinq ans pour avoir un rôle
parfois davantage encore c'est très long
moi ce que je vois tellement
extraordinaire c'est le il renoue avec
le modèle balzacien français enfin c'est
à dire que de moi ce que j'adore danser
romance et qui mélange tout la société
les politiques les avocats les les les
noirs des ghettos noirs américains
apprécient merveilleuse comparaison ce
qui peut faire c'est de prendre ma
retraite je connais la seule chose
honorable que je puisse des merci
beaucoup
alors qu'aramco publié aujourd'hui chez
robert laffont un livre qui s'appelle
mois charlotte simons
alors si c'est une autobiographie le
titre est mal choisi l'opéra madame
bovary c'est moi c'est vrai mais avant
d'avenir livre je voudrais justement
parler de la méthode
vous avez commencé par le journalisme
vous avez même inventé dans les années
60 le nouveau journalisme qui consiste
pour un journaliste a utilisé des
techniques littéraires pour faire un
journalisme qui se vit comme un roman et
c'est lors de ses débuts dans le
journalisme que vous avez appris à aller
enquêter sur le terrain je vais déclarer
les écrivains doivent sortir de leur
coquille pour aller chercher le matériau
de leurs livres c'est ce qu'ont fait
dickens balzac zola parcourir la société
comme un reporter sans porter de
jugement et en retranscrivant ce convoi
bref commencé par une enquête mais me
semble vraiment que aujourd'hui
l'imagination de l'être humain n'est pas
n'arrive pas disons à la hauteur de ce
qu'il va trouver sur le terrain la
réalité dépasse de loin la fiction en
mille ans vous ne trouverez jamais dans
votre imagination autant de choses que
ce qui se passe dans le monde ce que
font les gens de ce que pensent les gens
je donne un exemple est ce qu'on connaît
paris s'il tonne ici et là sont calmes
intéresse qu'un romancier aurait pu
imaginer une histoire dans lequel
linéaire belle héritière est retrouvé
sur un cas cette vidéo porno et ensuite
le reste du roman parlerait de ses
parents sont
le chantage que sèchement n'importe qui
peut imaginer ce genre d'histoires pas
très intéressantes ou bien une autre
histoire ou bien une belle héritière son
talent reçoit 10 millions de dollars
pour passer à la télé mais aucun
écrivain a eu l'idée de dire voilà cette
femme qui a gagné tout cet argent parce
qu'elle a fait justement cette cassettes
pornos n'y pense pas ce genre de choses
dépassent l'imagination du romancier
je crois que il faut vraiment c'est des
choses incroyables le monde est vraiment
très étrange
la réalité dépasse de loin la fiction à
l'imagination qu'il faut aller sur le
terrain et voir la réalité
contrairement aux autres écrivains vous
ne partez pas d'un thème ou d'un ou deux
personnages avant de trouver le milieu
dans lequel vous allez les maîtres mais
vous partez du milieu à part est
généralement le processus est inverse
non par rapport à d'autres romanciers
disons que moi ce qui m'intéresse
d'abord trouver un cadre contexte le
milieu mais dans le sens le contexte
général
alors ce sera par exemple wall street ou
bien les tribunaux comme dans mon
premier roman ou bien lors les
promoteurs immobiliers j'écris un roman
là dessus ou encore je ne sais pas par
exemple justement un campus
universitaire
et puis ensuite c'est les personnages
attendent des personnages entrent sur ce
décor et les pressions sociales jouent
un rôle tellement important et même les
décisions fondamentales sont prises à
cause des pressions sociales bon j'ai
pas déflorer d'histoire mais quand même
quand justement parlons de déflorer
charlotte perd sa virginité je sais pas
si les gens savent encore ce que c'est
qu'une virginité mais enfin elle prend
une décision sociale à ce moment là si
j'ai laissé ce garçon à des silhouettes
et tout nu à ce moment là mais je
n'empêche d'aller plus loin et bien on
va me traiter de
d'allumeuse et alors c'est genre de
décision est une décision non pas
exceptionnel décision affective une
décision presque sociale politique à la
limite et chante la vie est souvent basé
là dessus c'est des cons on réagit aux
pressions sociales
alors pour votre dernier roman donc moi
charlotte simons vous est parti d'une
enquête approfondie sur les campus des
universités américaines et vous avez
découvert d'abord que le sexe l'alcool
ont remplacé la culture et l'esprit
en tout cas pour ce que j'ai pu
remarquer aux états unis peut être à
l'exception de la suède les états unis
sur le seul pays où les étudiants de
premier cycle vivent sur un campus
c'est à dire que dans des dortoirs mixte
ce qu'on appelle les collègues
alors vous avez des jeunes dominent
plein de testostérone avec des jeunes
créatures du biel un côté des vous les
mettez ensemble dans les mêmes dortoir à
votre avis qu'est ce qui va se passer
avant jeudi
alors vous décrivez une jeunesse sans
morale ni discipline ou scrupules et
dans cette jeunesse sur ce campus comme
un chimiste qui mettrait une goutte
d'acide dans une éprouvette vous plongez
charlotte simons qui est une étudiante
sérieuse innocente coincé intello vous
la mettez là dedans et vous regardez
justement ce qui se passe oui je voulais
un personnage comme elle un personnage
qui est un devenir une fille
intelligente mais qui a un petit peu
disons imbue d'elle-même parce qu'elle
sait qu'elle a quand même beaucoup de
talent et elle pense pouvoir dominer le
monde grâce à son intellect et puis
alors elle se retrouve dans un monde où
elle est soumise à toutes sortes de
pressions sociales sexuelles alors je
vais pas prendre sept minutes mais y est
ce qu'on appelle la technique de la
séduction en sept minutes
cette vieille technique qu'est ce qui se
passe vous avez des groupes de garçons
et de filles c'est pas qu'ils ont un
rencard pour ce nom c'est des groupes
qui sont mises en place
dans une espèce de contexte on va
rencontrer quelqu'un dont vous avez des
versions d'un côté des filles de l'autre
alors un gars on remarque une fille
qu'il trouve attirante s'approche et se
présente et il va essayer de dire
quelque chose de très très cool du genre
je parie que tu en as marre qu'on me
prenne pour britney spears tout le temps
ou alors ou pour pour paris s'il tonne
ce genre de compliment vraiment très
content alors si elle marche dans la
combine
alors il s'assied à côté d'elle alors il
va l'effleuré sur le braz la seule
partie du corps que l'on peut toucher
sauf si l'on serre la main de quelqu'un
dont tout ça en l'espace de 2 minutes 30
et puis ensuite question suivante on
danse
ok ils se mettent sur la piste de danse
et à la danse consiste à quoi elle
consiste à rejoindre les parties ils ont
public vu bienne pardon et puis ensuite
qu'il s'agit de les frotter l'une contre
l'autre pendant à peu près trois minutes
donc on a maintenant il ya cinq minutes
30 qui se sont écoulées et pied au bout
de sept ans l'un demande à l'autre est
ce que il y a quelqu'un qui te ramène
chez toi en fait c'est un langage codé
pour dire on va dans ta chambre dans la
mienne
alors là on arrive aux sept minutes donc
tout est en quelque sorte times est
chronométré c'était quelque chose de
complètement nouveau que je connaissais
absolument pas alors au début
effectivement charlotte simone se croit
capable de résister à la médiocrité et
la vulgarité ambiante à la pression du
groupe et puis finalement elle finira
par abdiquer par se conformer aux autres
et votre théorie en fait c'est que tout
est statut
c'est la position sociale c'est le
standing qui mène le monde en fait
pensez par exemple au choix d'un
partenaire de vie bon c'est tout est
déterminé socialement quelquefois il y
aura quelqu'un qui va dire qu'on allait
il va épouser une femme qui à 50 ans de
plus que lui bon ça arrive assez
rarement ça peut exister ou alors vous
aurez je ne sais pas quelqu'un qui tombe
amoureux d'un animal bon là encore c'est
relativement peu fréquent généralement
c'est quand même
le statut social qui détermine ce genre
de choix même ses choix qui sont censés
être passionnel
[Musique]
comment faire
monsieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il ya un problème quand même c'est
que george bush a déclaré que charlotte
simons était un des meilleurs livres
qu'ils avaient lu je vais vous dire
quelque chose par rapport à ça sata des
grands chapitres de mon existence
le new york times a appelé ou et
journalisme a dit george bush adore
votre livre il leur recommande à tout le
monde
à votre avis pourquoi est ce que c'est
parce que se livrent leur appel ces
jours quand il était étudiant et
buvaient beaucoup dansé ces fraternités
jeudi je sais pas je ne sais pas
pourquoi est ce livre lui plaisent c'est
peut-être la qualité absolument
époustouflante de l'écriture c'est
peut-être tout simplement ça fasse une
épée alors la journaliste me dit mais
est-ce que vous avez voté pour bouger
répondu oui je n'apprends rien de
nouveau mais enfin en dix ans j'avais
voté pour bush bon y'a quoi 62 millions
288 1482 personnes qui ont fait la même
chose donc c'était pas si exceptionnel
que sable enfin bancaire lorsque j'entre
dans une salle avec d'autres écrivains
les gens me regarde d'un drôle d'air
c'est comme si j'avais levé la main prêt
à propos je bête vous dire je suis un
pédophile est ce qu on dit à quelqu'un
qui vous dit quelque chose comme ça
c'est un petit peu gênant dix ans donc
j'ai été un petit peu ostracisé ou en
tout cas on estimait que j'étais un
personnage un peu suspect à cause de la
façon dont j'avais voté mais cela étant
jeune homme ne commençait politique et
on n'a droit qu'à un seul vote ans aux
états unis on peut pas voter plus en
plus vous n'échapperez pas tamoul à une
interview bush au logis
alors ce sont des citations exactes de
george bush sur lesquels je vous
demandait de réagir par exemple quand il
dit je crois que nous sommes d'accord
le passé c'est fini tous d'accord en
effet il ya l'expression on dit bon il
faut aller de l'avant d'être souvent je
crois que c'était ça qui veut dire c'est
à dire que le passé est le passé
je crois que c'était simplement ça qu'il
voulait dire sinon la correction
relativement normal alors quand il dit
c'est évidemment un budget il ya plein
de numéro 2 dans la série c'est tout ce
qu'on peut dire sur le budget c'est
comme nombre il a déclaré aussi de plus
en plus de nos importations viennent de
l'étranger
[Rires]
une telle vérité s'il a dit je sais ce
que je crois je continuerai à exprimer
ce que je crois est ce que je crois je
crois que c'est ce que je crois et bien
c'est cité ses sources et tout ça par
rapport à ça quand même y'a pas beaucoup
d'écrivains qui ont eu l'occasion de
s'entretenir avec le président de
questions littéraires moi j'ai eu ce
privilège
une petite conversation avec lui et
curieusement il parle beaucoup mieux de
littérature que par exemple le rédacteur
de la publication intellectuelle la plus
prestigieuse des états unis qui
s'appelle le new york review of books
non c'est plus que le viseur
alors il je continue je ne manque pas de
réagir à chaque fois mais c'est pour le
plaisir de les entendre
il a dit nous prenons les bonnes
décisions afin de mettre fin à la
solution ça me fascine zone asie il a
dit cet argent est le vôtre vous avez
payé pour la voir j'aime pièce il serait
dit je crois que vous m'avez mal
sous-estimé très joli ça assez poétique
il a dit les gens s'attendent à ce que
nous échouions notre mission est de
dépasser leurs attentes
c'est quand même le dé les journalistes
qu a vanté tout ça non
la troisième priorité est de donner la
première des priorité à l'enseignement
est alors la dernière quand même si nous
ne réussissons pas nous courons le
risque d'échouer
[Rires]
world simone
robert laffont est là messieurs
[Musique]
tokyo merci merci d'avoir été avec vous
je vous laisse partir avec les monty
python
[Musique]